...Charles Ingram. I'm here at Guadalupe Island.
Whoa! I got a great white here.
A 14-footer just hit me two or three times under the bottom of the Zodiac.
There he is again.
As a combat diver, a technical diver,...
...and a former member of the Marine Corps's elite Special Ops unit known as Force Recon,...
...I've been through a lot of dangerous situations and challenges, man. I'm telling you.
The one thing that scares me is going face-to-face with a great white shark.
Look at the size of the hole it made.
Here he is. Look at that, the thing's bigger than my boat.
That's incredible.
The shark hit the pontoon of my boat hard.
There was no blood in the water and nothing to directly provoke it.
So what caused the attack?
What drives the great white's appetite for destruction?